欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课，:同学们 我们在学习国际站 整个运营技能的时候 第一步开始的时候 一定要先把这三件事情做好 你才能够一天就能够学习入门 无论你是有经验还是没经验 如果你现在运营知识非常混乱 或者是说你很久都没有做出成绩的 那么你也可以进行重新梳理一下自己的运营基础知识
然后构建成自己的运营思维框架 首先第一个我们要把整个国际站后面带问号的这个概念全部一天之内去掌握 第二个就是各板块之间的关联也要把它们理解清楚有什么关联 第三个就是各个板块的位置也要搞清楚 那么我们来具体来后台看一下 首先我们打开后台的时候是这样整个界面
只要我们在这些位置点击进每一个小小的板块或者是说进一些细分的板块 那么这里就会出现 比如说你看这些板块它是不是有一些指标 在这里是不是有一些指标 你看这些是不是带问号的这些是不是带问号的 你把这些所有的每个板块带问号的这些都去理解了 了解了 那么你就能够非常
非常准确的 知道 这些东西都是在表达什么 这些非常的重要 一定一定要去理解透彻 还有这个板块 我们把它点到这里 这样去看这里 这些平时也会有一些解释介绍 这些都可以在这些地方看 你看这些都会很多内容可以看 你把这些板块全部看完 我们看这些板块 板块与板块之间
有什么联系 比如说数据参谋里面 产品参谋 还有就是选持参谋 这些流量参谋 买家参谋 这些都有什么相关的 或者是说他们每个板块 具体都是在描述什么 或者是呈现什么样的数据 这些板块的数据 我能用来干什么 你要这样去思考 带着目的去学习 你才能够更快的去掌握这些技能
一定要想 这些板块的作用是什么 他的这些数据 我能用来干嘛 你就按照这个逻辑去思考 去学习就可以了 你看这些 比如说你的概念 对于某些概念不懂 你就在这里 输入你想要的 输入你想要的内容 然后就会出现一些具体的一个解释 或者是说你的概念不清楚 你也可以把这些关键词输进去 如果你
你实在不懂 在这里输入人工 那么发出去 那么他就会具体的 人工来服务你 你就只要把你的内容描述出来 他就会给你解答 所以说学习的第一个步骤 就是把这些后台的这些概念全部搞清楚 各个板块带着目的去学 这样的话 你才能够真正一天内 你基本就能够把这些全部记完了 这是第一次可能你没有那么记得清楚
或者是说有些指标或者是某些板块你记不清楚 那么你在后续的学习过程中 又会针对每个板块进行学习 这样一层一层的不断的重复 不断的重复 那么你的整个知识是非常的扎实的 而且你记得非常牢的 后面就是我们的应用的过程中 会无端的调用你这些知识 这些知识被用多了 就会形成一种肌肉记忆 或者是说形成一种
自动化的一个输出 所以说你就按照这个逻辑 第一就把这个态问号看完 第二个就是个板块的 有什么关联 你去思考 第三个就是这些板块都在哪些位置 后台哪些位置 哪个板块在哪个位置 这要记住到时候 我们讲接下去的内容 或者是说以后有人问你 或者是你想要找的内容 你都能够快速的找到 因为你非常清楚他在哪个板块 那么这节课就是讲
关于学习国际站之前 我们要做的这三件事情 我们要先把这三件事完成 再进行下一步的学习 不要急 这样的话 你学的更快 而且效果更好 这节课 我们就先讲到这里 下节课 我们再见